so i just want to say that i called you
either february or march 2018 before the
wedding
mm-hmm asking uh would you please give
me an interview
and you said i'm sorry it's not the
right time
and finally we get to sit down and have
this conversation well i remember that
conversation very well i wasn't even
allowed to have that conversation with
you personally
right there had to be people from the
comp sitting there
everything there were other people in
the room when i was having that
conversation
you turned me down nicely and said uh
perhaps
there will be another time when there's
the right time what is right about
this time
um
well so many things um
that were on the other side of a lot of
a lot of the life experience that's
happened and also that we have
the ability to make our own choices in a
way that
i couldn't have said yes to you then
that wasn't my choice to make
so as an adult who lived a really
independent life
to then go into this construct that
is um
different than i think what people
imagine it to be
it's really liberating to be able to
have
the right and the privilege in some ways
to be able to say yes
and to say that to yourself and not to
have to consult with anybody
at this point yeah to be able to just
make a choice on your own and just be
able to speak for yourself